it's useful to distinguish between
intelligence and imagination they are
different constructs as we would said as
we would say so
I like to view intelligence as all the
things all the thought processes
behaviors that allow us to learn what is
we're in the way the world is you know
whether or not it's in a classroom
situation we have to use our ability
learning you learning skills to
understand the material that's being
taught to us talk to us or we're reading
something with the comprehend what we're
reading or we have to observe things and
a lot of that draws on this executive of
brain network our ability to focus and
to synthesize information in our heads
at one time and remember them so that's
all the things involving our ability to
learn what is imagination are all the
processes that allow us to imagine what
could be so I like to I like to see
these as overlapping traits but not
completely overlapping so a lot of
creativity requires to learn what it is
so that we can go beyond it but if we're
just at the stage of learning what is so
we just have the knowledge
I don't think knowledge necessarily
equals creativity so creativity requires
both intelligence and imagination
creativity requires our ability to know
has come before so we can stand on the
shoulder of giants
it also requires ability to have great
foresight and vision to imagine the
world the way that it could be and when
we combine the two I think that makes us
much more likely we'll have creativity
so many of you might have heard of the
left brain right brain myth about
creativity that the left brain is not
related created much at all because it's
really boring and logical and super
serious and analytical and that the
right brain is where all the artistic
beauty comes out and it's very poetic
and it's I've seen like ads like for I
think I saw for Dad that had like left
brain right brain where it kind of makes
these distinction stuff well the reality
is that creativity involves interaction
of lots of different brain networks that
rely on both the left side and the right
side
the brain and all brain network is is
when you have lots of different parts of
the brain that are communicating with
each other to solve a certain task then
it's called a brain network and you find
that creativity drawls on multiple
interacting brain networks in particular
it draws on three brain networks that
are seem to be absolutely essential to
creativity across whatever field it is
whether or not it's science or it's art
one of those brain networks that is
important is what's called the executive
attention Network and the executive
attention Network allows you to
integrate lots of information in your
head at one time hold stuff in your
working memory maintain strategies that
you're currently working on it at one
time so you don't forget what your
strategy is or forget what you already
did and then redo it the executive
attention Network is also helpful for
inhibiting obvious responses or the
first things that come to your mind and
so creativity is important to access
remote associations so the executive
attention Network is going to be helpful
to inhibit the most immediate obvious
things that come to mind people who are
very good improv artists for instance
you know the first thing comes to mind
is usually not the most creative so they
they tend to like wait for the second or
third thing and that's one of the improv
activities so second major brain network
that's important is the default mode
network but I like to call it the
imagination network because it's a very
active as highly active every time we
turn our attention or focus of attention
inward and we focus on our daydreams we
focus on our future goals on when we're
ever trying to take the perspective of
solanell so it's it's very important for
having compassion for someone else
because it allows us to imagine what
someone else is thinking or feeling and
that's the imagination brain network and
they're their third major brain network
that's important for creativity that I
think it's a very underrated brain
network it's called the salience brain
network and that's associated with what
is most salient in our environment what
is most interesting to us before we
think through consciously about a
creative activity and even before we
activate our imagination there's a
process before both of that where we
have a subconscious process where the
salient brain network tags things is
interesting or not interesting in our
environment and it either feeds it to
our imagination network or to our
executive attention Network to pay
attention
- so that's where daydreaming comes from
so daydreaming is it is associated with
the activity in the imagination brain
Network and if our salience network
tagged something as extremely not
interesting in our environment in our
immediate environment
it'll pass the baton to the imagination
network and that's when we start
daydreaming and we start like tuning it
tuning out to the to the current
environment but creativity involves the
interaction of all three it's when we're
captivated by the moment or mindful but
we're also imaginative and we're also
motivated and passionate to engage in
the creative activity